Welcome to this deep dive where we explore Reza Shah Kazemi's spiritual ethos and the imam's warning to a governor that pride is war with God.
A war that traces inward to the conscience and outward into mercy.
Pride is war with God and mercy is what justice looks like when a ruler finally remembers who he is.
I mean imagine stepping into a new role.
Maybe you just got a big promotion or you're handed control over a massive project.
And you find yourself looking around the room feeling that quiet, almost invisible shift in your chest, that subtle thought whispering that you are finally where you belong, elevated above the rest, self-made, and just, you know, undeniably superior.
We barely even register that feeling today.
We just call it confidence.
We do, but we are looking at a profoundly jarring text today.
It's a letter of instruction from the imam, peace be upon him, sent directly to the governor he writes to.
And before this letter touches on tax collection, infrastructure or the daily mechanics of running a society, it drops an anchor that brings the entire concept of leadership to a dead halt.
What does he tell him?
The instruction is a terrifyingly direct command.
He says, do not set your soul up for war with God and just stop and consider the sheer scale of that imagery for a second.
Usually when you and I think of
of war, we picture something physical.
Clashing armies, drawn swords, shifting borders.
Visible rivals colliding on a battlefield.
But this letter is pointing to something completely invisible.
The Imam is warning that an internal disposition of arrogance, that quiet feeling of superiority you might carry into a meeting, is quite literally an act of open, hostile combat against the absolute.
I don't buy that yet, but how can a private feeling of superiority be called war against God?
It feels like a massive category mistake.
I can understand calling pride a character flaw or seeing how it makes a leader toxic, difficult to work with, or blind to their own mistake.
Sure, that makes sense.
But equating a private internal sense of self-importance with a cosmic militaristic rebellion against the Creator, that sounds like an extraordinary exaggeration.
War requires a rival and God has no rival.
Elevating a bad mood or a moment of vanity to the level of waging war on the absolute sounds like a rhetorical flourish, not a precise spiritual diagnosis.
That skepticism makes complete sense and the text actually addresses it by tearing away the social symptoms of pride to reveal its terrifying machinery because pride is not just a bad mood.
For someone wielding power, pride is an act of blatant theft.
Theft?
Like what are they stealing?
It is the misappropriation of something that fundamentally does not belong to the human being.
To see the
mechanics of this theft, we have to look at a profound divine saying that forms the beating heart of this teaching.
The saying declares, pride isness, my cloak and greatness is my robe.
Whoever contends with me over either of them, I shall cast him into the fire.
Oh, so we are dealing with the imagery of a sovereign's regalia here?
Precisely.
Let us unpack this image together.
Picture the regalia of a sovereign.
A cloak and a robe in a classical throne room are garments worn exclusively by the king to signify absolute majesty.
Those garments are never shared.
Right, they are never lent out to the court.
They are certainly never slipped onto the shoulders of a subject standing in the king's own hall.
When God is proud, it is pure, unadulterated truth because God alone possesses an underived absolute greatness.
But when a human being puts on pride, it is a catastrophic lie.
Because the human being is claiming ownership of something they are only borrowing.
I see the boundary line now.
A creature actually has no inherent greatness to be proud of.
If you are a ruler, every single faculty you possess is on loan.
Every single one.
The authority you wield is temporarily entrusted to you.
The intellect you use to strategize, the physical energy you use to get out of bed, your very existence from 1 microsecond to the next is being actively sustained by the creator.
To feel pride in those things is a profound delusion of possession.
You are gazing so deeply into the gift that you have entirely forgotten the giver.
And that delusion is exactly what transforms a simple thought into a declaration of war.
By wrapping themselves in the cloak of pride, the ruler is reaching for a garment that belongs exclusively to the sovereign and draping it over their own shoulders.
So it's a hostile act.
It is a creature attempting to set up a rival throne in the presence of the king.
It is, and this reveals A fascinating paradox about the direction of arrogance.
When you observe a toxic leader, their arrogance usually looks like it is aimed downward.
They look down on their employees, the strong despise the weak, the wealthy mock the poor.
We process that as a horizontal injustice between two people.
But this framework insists that arrogance aimed downward is actually rebellion aimed upward.
Yes, exalting yourself before others is a quiet denial of the sovereignty of the creator.
It is forgetting the reality that dominion belongs entirely to God every single day, not just in some distant afterlife.
When a ruler behaves as though the sovereignty of this day belongs to them, they are spiritually opposing reality itself.
But how does a human mind even justify that leap?
How do we convince ourselves that we own the robe?
To understand that, we have to look at the archetype of the proud soul.
The tradition examines Satan converting a mere difference into a defiance long before it ever infects human politics.
Satan was commanded to prostrate before the newly created human being, Adam.
And the command was crystal clear.
It was, yet Satan refused.
Think about the logic behind that refusal for a second.
What argument could possibly be made to the creator of the universe?
Satan reasoned that because he was created from fire and Adam was created merely from clay, fire is nobler than clay.
He took a difference in material and turned it into a hierarchy.
He did.
He observed a mere difference fire versus clay and converted it into a fundamental claim of superiority.
Then he weaponized that invented superiority into outright defiance of a divine command.
That is the blueprint for every single act of human pride that follows.
Okay, I can see how that maps onto us.
Think about how you or I might operate.
We observe
difference.
Maybe you have a higher salary, a sharper intellect, a better lineage, or a more prestigious political office than the person next to you.
take that difference, convert it into an innate superiority, and use it as justification to override the basic laws of decency, justice, and divine command.
So every arrogant leader walks in the exact procession led by that first refusal.
They do, and the disease does not announce itself with trumpets and a declaration of cosmic war.
It whispers.
slips in disguised as reasonable self-regard or wounded professional dignity.
If a ruler is literally in charge, why is thinking I order and am obeyed, considered corrupting or delusional?
Isn't stating I order and am obeyed just an objective fact of governance?
A governor is appointed to issue orders.
Society only functions because those orders are followed.
I struggle to see how recognizing the basic mechanics of your own administrative authority instantly plunges you into the archetype of satanic defiance.
That is a completely fair pushback.
It just feels like demanding an impossible level of self-effacement from someone whose literal job description is to command.
The danger is not in the act of commanding.
Society needs administrators.
The lethal danger lies entirely in where the ruler locates the source of their authority.
The specific thought, I order and am obeyed, is pinpointed as the very edge of the cliff.
When a ruler tells themselves this, they are quietly relocating the source of their power.
They stop viewing their power as a heavy trust lent to them by God.
And they start reading it entirely in themselves, in their own charisma, their own leverage, their own genius.
The text is incredibly specific about the sequence of damage this causes.
It corrupts the heart first, and it erodes religion second.
When power goes to a person's head, arrogance functions as a severe intellectual defect.
An intellectual defect?
How so?
It is an underestimation of the real.
The ruler only overestimates their own tiny sliver of borrowed power because they have completely lost sight of the overwhelming magnitude of the creator.
The psychological subtlety there is terrifying.
It means tyranny does not start with a massive dramatic decree to harm a population.
It starts with a silent shift in internal posture.
The ruler starts believing their own press.
They start performing their leadership for the applause of the room.
And that performance is identified as something far more insidious than simple vanity.
The Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, warned of a specific danger known as hidden idolatry.
The warning describes this condition as being more hidden than a black ant on a hard rock on a dark night.
When we hear the word idolatry, we tend to picture physical statues, ancient temples, or primitive rituals.
But the hidden idolatry of pretension happens entirely in the boardroom and the mind.
Imagine a leader who enacts A genuinely helpful public policy.
On paper, it looks perfect, but internally, they are only doing it to secure a legacy, to be praised by historians, or to be admired by their peers.
They have set up that human audience as a rival god.
Are rendering their worship and their service to their own reputation.
They might look devout, but their true object of devotion is the admiring gaze of the public.
And the consequence of that hidden idolatry is uniquely devastating because it reframes how we measure success entirely.
If you act solely for the applause of a human audience, you are eventually handed over to that audience.
You get the hollow praise you desperately wanted and absolutely nothing more.
It forces us to confront the terrifying concept of punishment drawn out by degrees.
We have this deep-seated assumption that if someone is succeeding, God must be pleased with them.
But this framework overturns worldly measures of success completely.
Worldly flourishing, an expanding book account, an untouched political career, vanquished enemies can actually serve as the mask of punishment.
It is administered gradually stage upon stage.
A ruler might look out from their balcony, see their treasury overflowing, and assume they are basking in divine favor.
But that very prosperity might be the instrument hardening their soul.
It traps them in a comfortable delusion.
They remain formally religious, maybe even
You just title among believers, but functionally they are covering over the truth with every arrogant breath.
Their apparent triumph is just the slow, quiet closing of a trap.
So we are looking.
At a war that starts by stealing the divine cloak, moves into the hidden idolatry of seeking human applause, and culminates in a worldly success that is actually a spiritual death sentence.
Which brings us to a massive shift in our vantage point.
We have to trace this war away from the external throne room, away from the applause of the crowd, and follow it into the most intimate, quiet court of all.
Pride is war with God and mercy is what justice looks like when a ruler finally remembers whose he is.
Okay, I see the transition happening here.
To wage war against the absolute on a cosmic scale, the ruler first has to wage war on their own internal landscape.
Before a tyrant can issue an unjust command that harms a single citizen out in the
physical world, an inner witness has to be violently silenced.
We're talking about the conscience.
Yes, and we need to redefine what that word means because modern secular frameworks treat the conscience as just a personal societal rule book.
We tend to think of it as a collection of norms we absorb from our parents, our culture, or our educational background.
Like if you grew up in one culture, you have one conscience and in another a different one.
But this spiritual ethos shatters that modern definition.
Conscience is not generated by society.
Conscience is a divine breath of discernment infused directly into the soul.
It is the very instrument that allows a human being to distinguish wickedness from righteousness in the 1st place.
Your soul did not arrive in this world as a blank slate.
It arrived already inscribed.
inscribed with the primordial covenant.
The text speaks of a moment before physical existence when the soul was brought forth and asked a single question, am I not your Lord?
And the soul testified, yes, verily we testify.
That innate awareness of divine lordship is the root system.
Moral conscience grows out of that spiritual consciousness.
To know right from wrong is literally to remember that ancient promise.
Therefore, whenever you override your conscience, whenever you feel that quiet tug telling you an action is wrong and you do it anyway, you are not just ignoring a cultural norm.
You are going to war with the trace of God within yourself.
You are actively attempting to erase that ancient covenant.
The true mechanics of tyranny.
A tyrant rarely stands up on day one and boldly declares an allegiance to evil.
They begin by systematically training themselves to no longer hear the voice that recognizes the evil.
They suffocate the divine breath decision by decision until it finally stops objecting.
I have to concede this point entirely.
The psychological truth of this framing is impossible to deny.
When you view the conscience as a divine infusion rather than a social construct,
The entire portrait of the tyrant snaps into focus.
It really does.
The outward tyranny a ruler inflects on a subjugated nation is nothing but a macro level projection of a tyranny they have already established within their own mind.
The ruler who proudly declares, I order and am obeyed to a broken population has already spoken that exact same sentence to their own conscience.
They have permitted the part of themselves that the tradition calls the soul that commands evil to seize the inner throne.
And all the burning cities and broken lives that follow in the physical world are just the radioactive fallout of that initial invisible inner coup.
And because the disease begins with an internal coup, the antidote requires A relentless internal counter-offensive.
What does that counter-offensive look like?
The imam provides the governor with the ultimate mechanism for self-reform, and he does not present it as some optional private hobby for the particularly pious.
He presents it as the absolute prerequisite for public justice.
He writes,
If your aspiration is to reform the people, begin with yourself.
Trying to fix a crooked society while your own soul remains bent is identified as the greatest of all faults.
Justice is defined as proper placement.
You cannot properly place the complex affairs of an entire nation if you have not first properly placed your own soul in a posture of profound humility before the creator.
That completely changes the nature of political ambition.
If a soul fancies it can stand on its own, independent of God, it inevitably takes its own desire as its God.
That is the genesis of all oppression.
The only thing that loosens the grip of the soul that commands evil is experiencing the deep, undeniable knowledge of your own nothingness before the real.
Only a soul that is profoundly lowly before God can ever hope to be truly just toward people.
Which brings us to a deeply counterintuitive instruction regarding who a leader should align themselves with.
Who does he say they should align with?
The imam commands the governor to find his approval with the common folk and to actively prioritize the poor over the elite.
If you read that through a modern political lens, it just looks like shrewd populism.
Secure the base because the elite are fickle.
But the instruction insists this is a vital spiritual imperative.
It is grounded in a reality that levels all humanity in a single stroke before God.
Everyone is absolutely destitute.
The immense wealth a ruler commands is merely borrowed against a poverty they share equally with the beggars sleeping at their gate.
So siding with the poor is not a political strategy.
It is aligning yourself with reality.
The poor represent the actual spiritual condition of every human being.
Courting the rich and seeking validation from the elite is buying into the illusion of self-sufficiency.
You see this principle perfectly embodied in an interaction the imam had with the over-strict ascetic.
Picture that person we all know who makes sure everyone in the room is intensely aware of their extreme lifestyle choices.
This ascetic had cut himself off from ordinary life, adopting severe physical deprivations, and he questioned the imam's rough clothing and coarse food.
The ascetic assumed they were kindred spirits, both rejecting the material world for personal purity.
But the imam firmly corrected him, drawing a crucial distinction that changes everything.
The ascetic was denying himself for the sake of private piety.
But the true leader, the imam explained, proportions himself to the weakest members of society out of a binding duty.
The ruler voluntarily lowers himself materially so that the poor never have to feel the unique sting of unshared comfort.
It is the exact same material austerity but driven by a completely opposite spirit.
The ascetic's austerity is turned inward, focused on building his own spiritual resume.
The ruler's austerity is turned outward, functioning as the quiet mortar that prevents a fragile society from cracking under the weight of inequality.
It is an unbelievably high standard.
The ruler refuses the false witchness of the world in order to hold it on the exact same terms as the weakest citizen.
But it requires genuine, agonizing detachment.
You cannot fake this.
No, you can't.
If a modern leader dresses plainly or takes the subway as a calculated piece of political theater while their heart still secretly covets absolute power, they are just performing the hidden idolatry we discussed earlier.
True detachment is the only key that works.
parable from an early Sufi master that perfectly illustrates the mechanics of this self-lowering.
The master approaches the door of the beloved and knocks.
A voice from inside asks, who is there?
The master answers, it is I, and the door stays firmly shut.
So the ego blocks the entrance.
Yes, so the master goes away, undergoes intense spiritual purification, strips away his ego, returns to the door, and knocks again.
Who is there?
This time he answers, it is thou, and only then does the door open.
The door of spiritual reality does not open to an ego that arrives full of itself.
It cannot be forced open by leverage, wealth, or political cunning.
It only yields when the eye has been emptied out.
When a leader achieves that level of emptiness, they finally stop governing from a place of defensive pride and start governing from a place of reliance.
And the natural, inevitable fruit of a life lived in reliance on divine mercy is the outpouring of mercy toward others.
A leader who keenly feels their own perpetual need for forgiveness is a leader who forgives.
That sounds like wordplay isn't calling mercy justice, just renaming softness.
If we are talking about a practical system of governance, justice and compassion usually pull in opposite directions.
Justice is supposed to be stern, objective, and punitive.
Compassion is soft, subjective, and lenient.
You constantly have to balance them against each other in the real world.
I understand why it looks like a contradiction.
Claiming that compassion is an intrinsic dimension of justice just seems like a poetic way of saying a ruler should avoid being too harsh, effectively watering down the strict demands of the law.
It is not wordplay at all.
It is a fundamental redefinition of what justice actually is.
The framework vigorously defends the position that mercy does not soften justice.
Mercy is an intrinsic dimension of justice because it aligns perfectly with the fundamental nature of reality.
Remember, our definition, justice is putting things in their proper place in accordance with the real.
So what is the nature of the real?
Look at the revelation brought by the prophet.
Nearly every single chapter begins by naming God as infinitely compassionate and ever merciful.
Mercy is the very first attribute established about the Creator.
Therefore, possessing A capacity for compassion is an innate affinity with the architecture of existence itself.
Mercy is what justice looks like when it is faithful to the nature of the God whose justice it is.
There is a spiritual arithmetic at work there.
The instruction explicitly states that dispensing mercy to others brings down divine mercy upon yourself.
It operates like a conduit.
When A ruler shows mercy to the vulnerable people beneath him, they open the channel for mercy to flow down from above.
To withhold mercy from a subject is to literally seal your own conduit shut.
It is the height of arrogant delusion to beg for leniency from the absolute while simultaneously crushing the weak in your own domain.
Yet we must be absolutely clear on this point.
Prioritizing mercy does not dissolve rigor or accountability.
How do we know it isn't just softness?
To prove that this is not mere softness, we only have to look at the terrifying
strictness of the Imam's justice whenever the public trust was breached.
The iron of justice is incredibly sharp when it comes to the rights of the people.
Consider the historical account of the Imam bringing a piece of red hot iron close to the body of his own blind brother.
His own brother?
Why?
Simply because his blind brother asked for a slightly larger portion from the public treasury than was his rightful due.
The Imam demonstrated in the most visceral way possible that granting such a request
out of family feeling would be plunging them both into a far more terrible fire.
The severity extends across his entire administration.
We see the thundering remonstrance and the direct threat of the sword directed at his own cousin for misusing funds.
We also read the severe oath-bound warning sent to a deputy governor promising catastrophic punishment for misappropriating even the smallest amount of the community's revenue.
And the ultimate proof of this unbending impartiality is the Imam's declaration regarding the Prophet's own grandsons.
What did he say about them?
He stated unequivocally that even they would receive absolutely no leniency if they dared to misuse the people's property.
The iron is real.
Nepotism wearing the clothes of justice is completely rejected.
But, and this is where the genius of the ethos shines, this terrifying strictness regarding the treasury is immediately paired with a breathtaking instruction regarding the treatment of the subjects themselves.
The instruction is to infuse the heart with mercy, love, and kindness for the subjects, and never to behave toward them like a ravenous beast of prey.
And the justification given for this open hand of mercy is one of the most magnificent statements of human unity ever recorded.
The subjects are described as being of two types, either your brother in religion or your like in creation.
Your like in creation.
Notice what is missing.
There is no third category.
There is no group of human beings, no marginalized faction, no foreign demographic who somehow falls outside the jurisdiction of a ruler's compassion.
We see this manifested perfectly in the story of the blind Christian beggar.
What happens in that story?
The imam is walking through the marketplace and sees this elderly man begging.
He asks about him, learns that society had
employed the man until he was infirm and then abandoned him, and the imam immediately orders his maintenance to be paid from the public treasury.
The man's creed was entirely irrelevant to his claim on the community's mercy.
His shared humanity, his shared creation, was the only metric that mattered.
That approach establishes A principle of social welfare that strictly refuses to discriminate.
It is a stunning historical application of the core philosophy.
The health of a society is not measured by the opulence of its elite or the size of its monuments, but by how it treats the people standing at its absolute weakest edge.
This specific refusal to make a person's creed the measure of their right to mercy has endured as a living thread.
It is central to the classical Ismaili reading of this ethos.
The Aga Khan has emphasized across a lifetime of guidance that faith must prove itself in the compassion it extends to the whole of humanity.
An undiscriminating mercy is the truest indicator of a properly ordered soul and a properly ordered society.
A mercy that does not pause to interrogate a freezing man about which God he prays to before it hands him a coat is the ultimate manifestation of justice.
When you view the entire landscape of this teaching, you see a single, unbroken movement.
It begins at the cosmic heights with the catastrophic theft of the divine cloak.
It descends into the boardroom with the hidden idolatry of pretending to possess underived greatness.
It moves inward, violently suppressing the divine breath of conscience.
But when that terrifying trajectory is reversed through the grueling work of self-reform, the soul empties itself and knocks on the door and says, it is thou.
It lowers itself to stand shoulder to shoulder with the destitute.
From that emptied, lowered position, it finally becomes capable of channeling a mercy that mirrors the compassionate nature of the real.
Pride is war with God, and mercy is what justice looks like when a ruler finally remembers whose he is.
We have traced this quiet war from the theft of divine regalia down into the embattled corridors of human conscience, out into the severe iron of public accountability, and finally into the open hands feeding a blind beggar.
The sequence is unbreakable.
The arrogant soul lies to itself about what it owns,
silences the inner witness that tries to warn it, and inevitably devours the weak.
But the humble soul remembers its own staggering poverty, listens closely to the ancient covenant echoing in its conscience, and extends a mercy that encompasses all of creation.
It brings us to a final, lingering question, one that applies far beyond the walls of any palace and reaches into the daily reality of every person listening right now.
Which voice inside you have you learned not to hear and what would listening to it cost you this week?